welcome back to las vegas now it is time
to race and battle with your friends and
family on mario kart at the saturday
night speedway randall capuno is here
from hyperx esport arena with all the
details
okay so i have to admit i'm not a big
gamer all good but mario kart
that's my that's my game that's the one
that's my game that's where i get really
like hype and intuit and competitive so
let's talk about what the saturday night
speedway is what are you guys doing very
cool so saturday night speedway is our
tournament event for our um mario kart
8. um usually happens on saturdays but
we're doing a holiday special winter
whiffs edition okay our naughty our nice
edition
on december 23rd and we like to do a
costume contest and our whole community
comes out so we're 120 episodes long now
so the community has been a part of us
for a very very very long time yeah
and it's pretty cool thing to celebrate
and just kind of get our gaming team our
gaming community together for a last
year event so just tell me about the
gaming community you know what what goes
into that who are you guys so it's
pretty cool
community to me is a lot of different
things it's where people can kind of
share we were talking sneakers a little
second ago and i'm feeling jordan
there's different like makeup things
like that and a gaming community is when
you know we'll go home and play video
games on our own but once you get a
whole bunch of gamers together just
sharing the same thing that everybody
loves it's a totally different
experience it's pretty cool that
everyone can talk about kind of the same
things or different tricks or shortcuts
right because it gets complicated it
gets complicated okay so we're talking
mario kart what's your
best number one tip for anybody out
there family friends playing together
what do they need to know ooh um get in
the zone feel it
feel part of the race kind of live it
like you're in real life and cut your
corners and make sure you pick up all
your items and and just live in it
that's racing the moment that's a good
one i like that okay how can people join
you guys really quick they can join us
over at thehyperxealv.com
they can go on our website and look up
all of our events that we're doing for a
gamer story week during the holiday
season and you can pre-register online
or you can pay for in person save a
couple bucks online if you do so well
thank you so much randall that's cool
all right